مطبق تحيطه اوكرانيا بهجومها المضاد صاحب
الحرب واقع لا تريدها ان يستاثر بخططها
ويساعد العدو باي طريقه باصابع موضوعه على
افواههم روج الجنود الاوكرانيون لصمت
عمليتهم المقبله وجددوا مطالبتهم بالتزام
السريه حيالها فوزاره الدفاع نفت وجود
اعلان عن بدايه الهجوم مضيفه ان الخطط تحب
الصمت لا بل شنت حمله على المواطنين الذين
ينشرون صورا او لقطات لمنظومات الدفاع
الجوي وهي تسقط صواريخ روسيه التركيز على
عدم افشاء موعد الهجوم يعود الى اهميه
عنصر المفاجاه في الحروب بحسب خبراء وقد
تكون لتصريحات الاوكرانيه المتضاربه الاثر
الاكبر فرئيس الاوكراني اكد جهوزيه قواته
للهجوم المضاد بعد ايام من اعلان تاجيل
الهجوم
على الرغم من عدم وضوح الرؤيه فيما اذا
كانت اوكرانيا قد بدات بالفعل هجومه
المضاد من عدمه دعونا نلقي معكم الضوء على
ما حدث في الساعات الماضيه في مقاطعه وفقا
لروايه روسيه الدفاع الروسيه قالت انها
صدت هجوما ضخما للقوات الاوكرانيه عبر خمس
نقاط جنوبي طبعا واحده من اربع مناطق
اوكرانيه ضمتها روسيا الخليفه الماضي تشمل
لوغانسكون القوات الاوكرانيه بحسب تصريحات
الدفاع الروسيه استخدمت ست كتائب
ميكانيكيه وكتبتاي دبابات في الهجوم
وبينما نفت موسكو ان تكون كيف قد نجحت في
اختراق دفاعاتها في القطاع الاكثر ضعفا
حيث تتصاعد المواجهات منذ اشهر اوكرانيا
اكتفت والتي غيرت التكتيكاتها العسكريه
اخيرا بشن هجمات متفرقه داخل العمق الروسي
اكتفت باعلاني تقدم قواتها البريه في
دانيتسكو وبالتحديد في مواقع قرب مدينه
التي فرضت قوات فاجن الروسيه سيطرت عليها
الشهر الماضي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات